Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Tess Wilkinson.
Ryan, who's a moral psychologist and a law
professor at the University of Pennsylvania
and also author of the recently released book
Full Proof How Fear of Playing the Sucker
Shapes Ourselves and the Social Order and
What We Can Do About It.
Really great having you on today.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Thank you so much for having me.
Speaker 1: So to start with, let's talk maybe
about what is the sucker construct or that
idea that you talk about and elaborate in
the book?
Speaker 5: Yeah, the the secret construct
is the idea that there are a whole bunch of
interactions or sort of dynamics transactions
in our everyday lives that take the shape
or can take the shape of a scam that feel
like, wait a minute.
I have a concern here that I'm about to or
I have I'm about to sort of voluntarily enter
into something that's going to leave me holding
the bag.
It's going to leave me with some unfair bad
results, thus making me a sucker.
And the reason for thinking about this as
a construct is that it can sort of be overlaid
on a variety of situations is not always obvious
that you have like a Ponzi scheme going on.
Speaker 1: What sorts of situations that might
not be obvious, right?
Like outside of actual Ponzi schemes, would
this be relevant?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think probably some of
the ones that are like most intuitive are
cases where you've gone to buy something and
the price is higher than you thought it should
be.
So I give an example in the book of my sister
going to buy a Gatorade from a place that
she really realized when she went in was a
tourist trap and sort of had this moment of
being like, you know, I'm not one of these
people who pay $6 for Gatorade.
But she was like actually really thirsty and
actually needed to get a Gatorade ASAP.
And she realized, What am I doing?
There's no reason for me to think I'm a sucker
here.
I just need to buy this drink and move along.
Other situations come up in everyday life
would be like deciding whether I have to believe
somebody who's giving you an excuse for something.
Hmm.
Deciding whether to let someone cut in front
of you in traffic.
You know, I think there's a lot of these little
dynamics where people sort of get their hackles
up and think like, what does it make me if
I let you, you know, whenever zoomed down
the breakdown lane and then pop in front of
me on the highway.
Speaker 1: And one of the arguments that you
make and that seems quite reasonable, is that
this fear of being the sucker impacts personal
choices where if we had maybe a more default
belief that getting suckered wasn't a possibility,
we would behave differently then having this
sort of guard up.
What are the sorts of personal choices that
people would make based on this fear of being
suckered?
Speaker 5: Yeah, maybe I can give you two
examples from two different sort of sides
of the kinds of decisions you might make.
So I think about this as impacting decisions
that about that are about like getting ahead
and then impacting decisions that are more
like other regarding so how you sort of do
good rather than sort of how be good in the
world, I guess.
So one example would be say, personal investing.
So there's actually a really nice study that
sort of asks people that ask people in two
different conditions of a of an experiment,
how much money would you invest in this company
if I gave you the stats of this company?
And the stats of a company are either, look,
there's an 80% chance that investors break
even, 15% chance that investors double their
money or 5% chance that they lose it all.
And the 5% chance was this was described a
half a subject as a 5% chance that the founders
of the company didn't.
They had underestimated sorry, they'd overestimated
consumer demand.
They made a mistake.
Speaker 1: Honest mistake.
Speaker 5: Honest mistake.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So you can see where it's going, right?
So the other half of the subjects are told
there's a five that 5% chance that 5% downside
risk.
That's the rest of these guys are frauds.
Mm hmm.
And you know, the numbers there are the same
in.
Right?
In both cases, there's a 95% chance of breaking
even or doing better than breaking even.
But people had really different responses
to what to do in those situations.
People were way less willing to invest in
the maybe fraud situation.
You know, only a 5% risk.
Speaker 1: I guess the difference, if you
wanted to argue that there is some logic to
that difference would be, well, if they're
frauds, then we're definitely not getting
our return.
Whereas if they're wrong, we might just get
a different return or market conditions might
change.
I mean, I get like it's set up in a way where
you're trying to eliminate that, but there
there would be some argument like that, I
guess.
Speaker 5: No, And I think that that the what
you're describing is actually exactly how
this works psychologically, like I think you
are.
You're exactly right to think that the way
it works is that once you invoke the fraud
possibility, people basically have a whole
bunch of ways that that sort of fraud reasoning
affects the way they think about the numbers.
Right.
I think, well, the fraud number is really
bad.
That one serious.
The other number doesn't feel as serious.
Right.
Kinds of reasons that you describe and you
can think about.
The idea is like how how prone are people
to fighting the hypo?
Right.
They're sort of the what's happening in the.
Is that you're sort of resisting the math,
which is I think exactly what people are doing
in the real world saying, well, wait, the
math doesn't feel as bad to me.
Right.
And part of the argument is like, that's exactly
that's exactly the point.
The math feels worse once you invoke the possibility
of a scam.
Speaker 1: Rather than just a mistake.
Yeah, that's an interesting one.
What?
What was the other example from a different
area?
Speaker 5: Yeah, the other example is I think
that people that a lot of people find pretty
intuitive is that people can get really nervous
or wary about feeling like a sucker when they
start to get in, when they're engaging in
basically like a charitable transaction.
So if you've ever heard of if you've ever
heard people sort of resisting donating money
or resisting even giving money to somebody
who's asking for money on the street, for
example, they say, yeah, what are they going
to spend it on?
Right.
And there's a sort of what what does it make
me?
If they're going to spend this money on something
that I don't approve of.
Right.
That that's sort of a consistent fear and
there's a whole bunch of sort of animals.
So there's a whole bunch of pleas, for example,
from food banks.
Speaker 4: Yes.
Speaker 5: We're in the phone bank, say we
we really appreciate donations, but please
donate cash.
Speaker 3: Mm hmm.
Speaker 5: Cash is what we need because we
know what the needs are of the people who
are serving.
We don't pay retail prices, right?
We pay wholesale prices.
And we can and we can buy things in bulk.
And a lot of people really resist donating
cash.
It's a lot easier, I think, to raise to to
to do a charity drive where you're asking
for in-kind donations, you know, toys, cups,
food, cans of of, you know, canned goods rather
than cash.
And there's some really interesting studies
that suggest that people basically feel like,
well, cash is so easy to abuse.
Cash is going to you know, if I give cash,
I'd be worried or people are going to do with
it.
Whereas if I give a can of beans.
Speaker 1: There's only so many things you
can do with that.
Speaker 5: Yeah, exactly.
It's kind of exploitation proof, right?
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 5: Right.
So, so it's sort of exploitation proof.
And I know I can see how people can sort of
justify that in their minds, like what's going
on there.
But actually, for any individual, if I was
going to donate or say food to a food drive
for me to take to get into my car, right.
And drive to a store and pay retail prices
for a bunch of rice and beans and then to
bring them to the food bank is actually a
huge waste of time and money.
And for all I know, they need baby formula
right now, rice and beans.
And so it's actually a way of making this
donation way less valuable and less and way
more costly for me.
Speaker 1: When it comes to I mean, we're
sort of kind of getting into some stereotyping
of like, what would the folks who are on the
receiving end be likely to do if they received
A versus B?
Can you talk a little more generally about
how stereotyping plays a role in the sucker
construct?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think it plays like a really
under appreciated role or I should say, actually,
maybe I want to flip the question a little
bit and argue that the ideas we have in the
fears we have about playing the sucker are
actually constitutive of a lot of intergroup
stereotypes, of a lot of the most pernicious
sort of avenues of bias in those in the culture.
So if you think, for the example I've raised
about about the donations, this is a place
where I think a lot of people can see that
we live in a society where there are stereotypes,
for example, about people living in poverty.
Right, Right.
That actually what they're doing is taking
your taxpayer dollars and using them to avoid
entering the workforce.
Those kinds of stereotypes are leveraged to
basically reduce solidarity, I would say.
Right.
To sort of like to come between people who
want to do the compassionate thing and the
the compassionate or the sensible or the humane
or however you would describe it, to come
between them and that instinct and sort of
create rifts between people.
Speaker 1: And it does seem to follow from
that belief that if you believe that, you
would say, well, by donating the cans rather
than the money, I am acting logically based
on this stereotype about the group that would
receive it.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think that that's right.
That's I mean, I think that that's sort of
exactly where people go.
The more suspicious you are of the people
to whom you are donating goods or money.
Right.
The more you go out of your way to only make
a very particular kind of donation.
I mean, and I would sort of still argue that
that is still sort of at its core an inefficient
donation, in part because there's not actually
I mean, in part because the the the stereotype
content is we don't have reason to believe
it's true.
Right.
I think it's you know, it's it's bringing
in a bunch of sort of pernicious classism,
basically.
Speaker 1: When we think about different types
of.
So, you know, there's like hustles, scams,
Ponzi schemes, business practices to some
degree.
You know, we were recently talking about the
FTC now is looking at passing a law that says
you have to be able to cancel a gym membership
in the same way that you sign up for it.
Right.
So it can't be you sign up in 30 seconds online,
but then you've got to go in in person with
a notarized form in order to cancel it.
If that's how you have to cancel it, then
you've got to sign up that way, which would
never happen because the whole point is reduce
friction for the sign up, increase friction
for for the cancellation.
That's like a business practice, which you
can argue is a sort of hustle or scam.
But people's sort of resistance to it is very
different than someone on the street asking
for money.
What's happening psychologically there?
Speaker 5: Yeah, it's a great question.
So and I should say that the gym example is
like very close to my heart, in part because
my day job, I'm teaching contracts.
And so it's a lot of my research is about
consumer contracts and the way people interact
with this whole world of sort of clicking
to clicking to agree.
Yeah.
And one of my deep concerns about the way
that consumer contracts operate in the world
is that people do feel like they are bound
to these deals and sort of don't perceive
them as this as exploitation in the way that
you might expect given how hard it is to get
out of your gym membership.
Right, Right.
So so part of the argument that I'm that that
you're picking up on is the argument that
it feels worse to be taken advantage of by
someone who you thought was your subordinate
or peer than someone who you already assumed
had a bunch of power.
Do you think that a scam is a power play?
And I think it is.
I think I think there's a lot it's about power
in part if you feel like you've been scammed,
one of the experiences you have is a feeling,
is a feeling for a foolish and humiliated
or sort of a low standard.
The lowering of your sense of like what?
My belonging in this group, my sense of dignity
and belonging, being able to be made to feel
that way by someone who you already assumed
had power or or you feel you feel less if
you feel as acutely if it's coming from someone
who you already thought was sort of making
the world go around.
Whereas if you think about it as people who
you thought were who you assumed were sort
of in positions of less power than you, and
it feels like you've been kicked down further
on the sort of social ladder in ways that
feel really terrible.
Right.
And where they feel like destabilizing, like
what is my sense of status and belonging in
the in this community that's interesting.
Speaker 1: And that, you know, when I think
about $35 overdraft fees on a checking account,
which might add up to 500 bucks versus someone
suckered you out of $500 worth of Bitcoin,
The latter is sort of someone just like you
who figured out a way to get $500 in Bitcoin
from you versus something that seems more
systematic and sort of like a business oriented
transaction where you could argue I mean,
I'm not saying that you're told the overdraft
fees upfront.
Like I understand that it's not exactly the
same, but the feeling would come away being
dramatically different.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think that that's right.
I think people feel like there's a there's
a theory in psychology that I like that I
like a lot called system justification.
And it's the idea basically that people are
sort of motivated to explain that the system
works, right?
So you're motivated to say like, well, you
know, the banks have to make their money somehow.
And I, I knew, you know, I was alerted beforehand
that his overdraft fee even so, even though
just to be clear, my own my argument is like,
you know, that's deeply problematic.
Like, in fact, nobody can read all these terms
and conditions is right.
This is having all of these sort of fines
and fees be associated with this sort of culture
of scolding people about reading the fine
print I think is super cynical.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 5: But I think you're right that when
it comes from like, as you say, like a peer,
like someone who sort of like leverage their
position to get one over on you, even though
you're both just people out there in the crypto
world.
If it feels like, yeah, I've been like I sort
of have been demoted in this social world.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask you about
in terms of like full proofing ourselves so
that we can't be scammed in specific.
Areas.
You can always find tips when it comes to
those phishing emails.
Here is the way that you handle that.
When you go to buy a car.
Don't let them make the conversation about
your monthly payment.
Like first talk about the sale price, then
deal with fine you.
There's within specific areas, there's all
these ideas.
Are there more overarching principles or are
they really the types of principles that lend
themselves to paranoia and are less useful?
Practically speaking.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
You know, in some ways I have this deeply
unsatisfying answer to that question, which
is kind of like that.
Part of the feel of that part of my view is,
is to surrender more often, to let it be that
in that there are more cases in which you
have thought through what were the consequences
in this case?
BE of of being sort of a little bit duped
or scammed or whatever.
And if they aren't that big to just let it
go right.
In the context that you're describing, like
buying a car, that's exactly the kind of context
where you want to be really have your antennae
up.
Are you want to be like especially wary.
Speaker 1: The stakes are certainly higher.
Speaker 5: The stakes are high.
And, you know, the only goal is to get out
of there with a car that you can afford.
It's not you.
You'll have a goal of like making friends
with the salesperson, right?
There are always other contexts in life where
you can sort of get this kind of sucker prickle
at the back of, you know, like, Oh, is this
going to happen to me?
That happened.
I mean, this, for example, in life of a teacher,
that's me, right in the in your life as a
parent, as a friend, where you start to get
that that little perk.
And it really helps to think, well, wait a
minute, what actually is the risk here?
How big of a deal would it be if I gave a
student an extension on paper of they didn't
technically need for the reason they something
they need it, right.
That would probably be, to me a small deal.
By contrast, it would feel like a really big
deal if I treat a student callously who actually
needed my help.
Right.
It's about like weighing the real risks in
sort of going back to that investment example.
Right.
Of like asking yourself to talk through the
math a little bit, to say, is it right?
Do I really think that that my sort of focus
on this, you know, risk of a fraudster is
something that I believe in in some deeper
way?
Or is this a little mistake?
I'm making a sort of a way my attention has
been been torn away from the place where it
really belongs.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And the example about the paper and the extension
also relates to an asymmetry in, if I'm correctly,
assessing versus incorrectly assessing.
And that certainly can be a big factor as
well.
The book is Fool Proof How Fear of Playing
the Sucker Shapes Ourselves and the Social
Order and What We Can Do about it.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Professor Tess Wilkinson.
Ryan, really appreciate your time and your
insights today.
Speaker 5: Yeah, thank you so much for having
me.
This was a great.